little NS X the rapper who um infamously
made a music video of him getting um
violated by the Devil Himself little
nasx then said he was he was becoming
Christian and he was going to go study
the Bible at a Christian college and he
made a big media campaign about this
even though the college said we've never
heard of this guy he's not doing that
then he came out with this Blasphemous
music video very sacriligious video that
we covered on the show briefly and now
he's responding to the backlash against
his sacrilege he says oh you know I I
had no idea that people would be
offended I obviously meant no
offense so first of all when I did the
artwork I knew like there would be some
upset people or whatnot uh simply
because you know religion is a very
sensitive topic for a lot of
people but I also didn't mean to like
mock this wasn't like a you
to you people um you to the Christians
like you know it wasn't it was not that
it was literally me saying oh I'm back
I'm back like Jesus and I will say
though with the communion
video with me eating the crackers and
juice I uh I thought that video was
going to be the video to lighten the
moood to take it down like less serious
what not I thought that was something
that we all wanted to do with kids and
whatnot but I didn't
understand the idea of
um you know the reality of what it is
you know it's me eating the commune
which is like the symbolism of like
Jesus's blood and and bones or something
like that I don't remember completely
but um I did not mean it to as like a
cannibalism thing or whatever the
freak but I do apologize for that yeah
really sincere doesn't that seem really
sincere I I don't know I I always try to
look for the best in people and give
people the benefit of the debt but he's
obviously not sincere at all he's
obviously still trolling oh I'm so
shocked I made this music video right
after I made this video where I was
getting violated by the devil and uh I
made another music video where I put
satanic imagery all over the place incl
including in heaven and presented myself
as Jesus on an upside down crucifix so
satanic image there and had all sorts of
devils in heav I was just so weird I
can't I didn't obviously I didn't mean
to offend you no man I I just didn't
know you know and then when I when I
mocked the the Eucharist when I mocked
the Blessed Sacrament I just didn't know
CU I didn't what I didn't know it was
like what supposed to symbolize like
like uh Jesus's bones and stuff bones
and stuff yeah I don't know I didn't
look it up you could have looked it up
before you made the video if you were
actually wanted to apologize but he
probably did look I'm sure he looked it
up and he's but he's mocking us he's and
he's mocking more than mocking us as
Christians he's mocking God God is Not
mocked it's not a good thing to do not
not something to be
recommended so okay he keeps trolling
he's going to keep doing it he'll his
next music video will be the same thing
and he'll keep the shtick up as long as
he can and then his foot will slide in
due time and that will be very sad for
him this is all he can do and more than
little nasx this is all the devil can
do nothing that little nasx has done is
in any way original it's all just d R
ative and it's all sa satire and parody
that's all he can do the Black Mass
which is the Satanic ritual is just a
parody of the true Mass all of his
commentary is just is just mocking True
Religion that's all they can do that's
what the devil does the devil just kind
of mocks you the devil just he can tempt
you he can mock you he can he can Vex
you a little
bit but he can't really do anything new
because God is being being itself you
know when Moses asks God in the burning
bush says who shall I tell them that you
are God says I am that I am meaning go
God is
is
being full stop period being and so
uh God is what is really real really
truly real and uh the opponents of God
they're not they're not the opposite you
know it's not like the yin and the Yang
they're just they're they're a privation
of goodness and truth and Beauty they're
a privation of of being they're nothing
just a little car bunkle on the side of
the bark of Peter so he'll he'll keep
keep this up for a while and he'll he'll
keep laughing until he's not laughing
anymore but the one thing he won't do is
have an original idea these guys never
ever do I think Mike Lee the Republican
libertarian senator from Utah made a a a
pretty good argument as to how absent a
lightning strike whether it be from the
sky or from the Democrats Trump is the
nominee look whether you like Donald
Trump or not whether you agree with
everything he says or not he is our one
opportunity to choose order over chaos
and putting America First Over America
last it's time to get behind him and
look in presidential campaigns there are
always a lot of promises made my
favorite kinds of political promises are
Promises Kept Donald Trump has kept
promises that he's made as he's
campaigned in the past we know what kind
of President he will be and so whether
you agree with him on every point or not
if you are not content with the status
quo the status quo of lawlessness of
putting America last it's time to get
behind Donald Trump and I wholeheartedly
endorse Donald J Trump in his bid for
the presidency in
2024 clear enough and it hearkens back
to a political Maxim first put out there
by Otto von bismar which is that
politics is the art of the possible the
art of the
attainable the art of the next best and
there are going to be people who don't
love Trump or who liked him in 2016 or
2020 but don't like him anymore they
think this guy would be better or that
guy would be better or whatever but what
Mike Lee is saying here
is there's clearly one candidate
who can in any way unify the GOP there's
one guy who has proved himself to be Far
and Away clearly the leader of the pack
and he's the guy and maybe you prefer
another guy and maybe you wish that he
weren't the but he just is the guy and
so we've got to put the interesan
squabbles aside we've got to quit
burning GOP money when there is no path
to Victory really for any of the other
candidates and we just need to be a team
player wasn't that the point of The
Pledge before the GOP debate The Pledge
was you need to agree to support the
eventual nominee and everyone but Trump
signed it Trump said I'm not going to
sign that because I don't really believe
it and I'm not I'm I'm not going to
promise something that I'm not going to
deliver on and the other candidates
signed it and then Chris Christie the
first big one to drop out of the race I
actually didn't mean that as a pun but
there you have it he drops that and then
he says I'm not going to support Trump
oh so you're a liar so you you're you're
just the thing that you accuse Trump of
being but Lee is saying look Trump was
good maybe you wish he did more or he
did things differently but he was a good
president he did more for conservatives
than a lot of other Republicans have and
anyway he's the guy now so I'm going to
get behind him and you should too that's
his argument and it's a fairly
persuasive argument it might not be the
most idealistically satisfying but it is
what it is man this is the way the race
has shaken out what a great clip now
hold up ring that Bell subscri subcribe
to the Michael NS YouTube channel we'll
see you next time